in the last video we talked about the
situation where I'm taking six shots on
a goal we knew my probability of making
any given shot and we wanted to do is
figure out the probability distribution
of me making K shots in general we
defined our random variable X is the
number of shots I make out of six so I
realize in that last example that
examples right back here that the math
gets a little hairy right you're dealing
with 0.7 then x 0.3 to the fifth and all
of that so got a little complicated and
and what better thing to do if you have
numbers like this that even bet in the
calculator then to use Excel and you'll
see that you'll see that Excel is a
fairly powerful tool for probability and
statistics and in general for a lot of
types of simulations if you don't want
to actually write serious code you can
do actually do fairly serious things
with with something as you know
seemingly not so simple or not so
serious as Excel but it's actually quite
serious so let's see so let's say that
I'm going to take let's define n I'm
going to say that that is I'm going to
take six shots the probability of me
making any shot I'll say is 0.3 that's
what we did in the last video the
probability of a Miss right the
probability of a Miss let me say let me
actually write a little bit more
explicitly probability of a of a make it
is equal to 0.3 and the probability of a
Miss I'm going to write and instead of
just writing 0.7 there because we know
it is let's just make it a little bit
dependent on the first one so we'll
write a formula say that's equal to one
minus and then we'll select this cell
right here it's equal to one minus
probability that I make a shot and
notice it just calculated it for is 0.7
let me zoom in a little bit there you go
that might be easier for you to read
because I know it gets really small on
YouTube so and this is neat because now
if I were you know we want to see what
happens when this becomes 0.2 that
automatically calculates 2.8 so that's
neat let's put it back 2.3 and now let's
do a bunch of rows so that we can
calculate the probability that you know
our random variable X could be 0 shots
or 1 shot or whatever so so let's say
that K let me make a row called
a so that's the number of shots we need
to make 0 1 2 3 4 4 5 6 you can't see
the sixth one right now let me just go
up here and now you can see everything
that's so probably and then we need to
figure out the binomial coefficient so
that's the well actually let's do it
first let's say the the probability of
making any one of those any any one way
of getting you know no shots or any one
way of getting exactly three shots so
it's going to be it's going to be the
probability of a make so you're going to
make it you're going to make K shots
times the probability of a Miss so if
you make K shots how many do you miss
you miss n minus K and I'm not doing
anything fancy in Excel right here I'm
just kind of writing a label that
hopefully is a little intuitive for you
so this is the probability this row is
this column is going to be the problem
like in this cell right here it's going
to be the probability that you any one
particular way of making three shots and
missing three shots well it's going to
go into that cell eventually and then
you need to note you needed the binomial
coefficient so you're going to need and
it's going to look a little bit messy
now but it's going to be so you want n
choose K so essentially this row is
going to say what's the probability for
example in that in this column in this
cell right here we'll have the
probability of you know making the first
and missing the next 5 or missing the
first 5 and making the last one there
are going to be the same probability
you're going to have one make and 5
misses and then this cell we're going to
say well how many different ways can I
make just 1 out of 6 and that's why I'm
going to choose 1 out of 6 right K is 1
and n is 6 that's going to go there and
then we're going to and then we can
calculate what the probability that our
random variable is equal to K is equal
to this value and it looks all fancy but
it's exactly what we did in the last
video with with you know my little my
little my little doodle tool that I use
which is actually just Microsoft Paint
for those of you wondering because I get
a lot of emails and I'm tired of saying
it's just Microsoft Paint
all right so what's the probability that
I make zero and I miss and I miss six
right because that's what they're saying
here so this is going to be the
probability of me making a shot and I'll
put those dollar signs that kind of
fixes it on this cell the probability
that I make a shot to the caithe power
right so I make zero shots times the
probability that I miss a shot that I
miss a shot for those dollar signs there
so that it fixes on that cell to the N
minus K power right in this case would
be the sixth power I missed six shots so
to the let me put in parentheses and let
me fix on that cell n minus K power and
there you go there that's that's the
probability for example of me making the
first and missing the next five or this
could be the probability of me getting
the first one the first shot then
missing the second and getting the last
four missed so at any of one of those
situations and how many of those
situations are there
well that's n choose K so that's equal
to n choose K that's the same thing we
did before
that's all this factorial stuff here
that's n choose K so I'm just going to
express the binomial coefficient
expression in excel so it's the
factorial of how many we're choosing
from how many shots were taking in the
excel function for that is fact so we'll
take the factorial of six and we'll
divide it by put a parenthesis here the
factorial of K right times the factorial
factorial of n let me fix that n minus K
and I know it fell off I mean and - okay
you put some parentheses there so
parentheses match it up and actually
this just what fixes on this selim you
put an F for there and then there you go
there's only one way to choose zero
things out of
six things right that's what that tells
us and then the probability that my
random variable is equal to K or in this
case that I make exactly zero shots is
equal to the probability of any of the
specific ways of making zero shots times
the number of those ways there are times
that so that's the probability of making
zero shots and this is the cool thing
about excel we can now select these
cells and just go into this right hand
corner just drag it down and we'll do
that calculation for all of them and
this is neat because it calculated the
binomial coefficients right this is 6
choose 3 right n is 6 K is 3 this is 6 2
3 20 it's nice and symmetric like you
would expect but the probabilities
aren't that symmetric because you know
we have point three and point seven so
it's not like the the flipping a coin
example that was point five on either
side and all right these aren't
symmetric and then when you multiply
these of course these don't look
symmetric but it's hard to look at these
numbers so actually let's just use the
powers of Excel to graph this
probability distribution so let's say
insert chart and I'm always I'm clumsy
at inserting charts so let me see the
data I think this is how I do it I
select the data there you go and then I
need to select I need to select the
label to category X labels okay that's
going to be that right there and then
let's see next that looks good that
looks good I don't want to have anything
else I don't need a legend I don't I
don't want to show a legend there you go
all right now I think I am finished my
data labels yeah that's fine okay finish
I don't wanna get too fancy and then
with the letters all thing we make this
bigger for you so this is neat and I
wish they didn't roomate the font so big
but you get the point this is a discrete
probability distribution of me making
egg in this case K shots out of six
right and this was based on the fact
that my probability of making any given
shot was 0.3 and let me see if it'll
actually and I'm not making any promises
here let me see if I can actually make
it so that it changes if I make it point
two does
change yo a change look at that that was
neat let me bring this up a little bit
so his need is so if I have a 30% chance
of making a free throw that is my
probability distribution my discrete
probability distribution of making K
shots right this is my probability of
making no shots I think it was like
roughly oh it even gives us it tells us
it's point 12 percent or it's 12 percent
chance of making no shots my probability
of making four shots is only six percent
I know you can't see it but that little
window that shows up right under my
pointer says 0.06 so this is neat and
since the way we set it up we can
actually change it so that if I have a
higher probability of making a shot and
now it looks pretty symmetric now my
chances of making four shots is the same
as my chances of making two shots and if
I if I'm a riff I'm really good at
making baskets then you know I have an
80% you know probability of making any
given shot now all of a sudden the whole
distribution has shifted to the right
but I just want to show you one this is
I think a pretty neat way to use Excel
and hopefully it's not too daunting and
the other thing is these are all
examples of binomial distributions and I
wanted to give you an example that might
be a little bit more relevant to your
everyday life and it actually is a it's
it's a you know that the probabilities
of making and missing aren't the same
they change if they are the same then
you end up with a situation like that
let's say you're you're a horrible
basketball player and you only have a
10% chance of making any given shot so
there's a very high probability that you
make no shots let's see this is a you
know there's a 50 there's a 50 53
percent chance you make no shots and
then there's a 35 percent chance you
make one shot and so forth and so on but
this is pretty neat this by itself is
kind of a fun fun little toy and
hopefully you you have enough
information to do it yourself or maybe
experiment with more what happens what
if you have more than and what n goes to
actually maybe I'll do that in the next
video anyway see you soon